[Music]
you seem very calm and which is very
nice you seem pretty centered in common
anybody have you crazy and I find
traveling to be somewhat stressful it
doesn't seem to be affecting you that
you're traveling a lot I know that's
funny
well sometimes recently I was traveling
I had to go to New York City which I
love I love going back and um I was
without my kids on this particular
particular trip but um I I do I do feel
kind of relaxed when I travel cuz I have
like this um I did this thing this this
time where I didn't want to walk
somebody told me that you don't have to
walk through those scanners if you don't
want to you can you can opt you get
chosen for a scanner you can you can opt
out apparently I've not done that I've
gone through the scanner but you opted
out I just opted out of one you're
supposed to go through that does like a
little X racing of you I opted out
because somebody said oh maybe don't do
that so I opted out and they were like
we have an opt-out and so I went and
waited and then they um they were like
just so you know they said you know you
can do we're gonna do like a patch on
this and you can do it out here or you
can do it in private and I was like I'll
do it out here it felt like like I was
already like it was already feeling like
a spa experience or like a massage down
by the TSA was a spa experience really
like she explained she was like you know
I just want to explain I'm gonna put
gloves I'm gonna pet you here and here
and here and here and I was like great
it sounds good was that creeping her out
at all no not at all yeah but any help I
have I have this associates to she
methodically went through it but I have
this thing that I that's a very real
response it's called ASMR and I've
talked about in a talk shows before it I
am it's actually called ASMR it's on
Wikipedia and it's called like auto
sensory meridian response and it's where
I get I get a kind of tingling sensation
in my body certain I'm slow hand
movements trigger it or soft voices or
like a soft touch will trigger like a
head orgasm really that's fantastic
wait were you experiencing that when the
TSA person was touching you I I did yeah
I get triggered a lot at the airport
like I love with people have plap if you
if people are running plastic gloves I
like when they check your like if you if
you have your your check that you go
through the luggage I like when they
have the gloves out and they check it or
I love when I get checked and they have
to go through my luggage with the
plastic gloves and they have to go
through each item like methodically
swiping and going through it or is
Sexual what you're saying sounds sexual
to me like you're getting a sexual is it
you said head orgasm I think I'm within
my rights oh my god no it's not sexual
both men and women get it and you can be
triggered by a man or a woman it doesn't
matter it's just a certain type of soft
voice or a soft hand movement or you
know like a texture like what if I
slowly rub my hands this microphone is
that doing anything for you no it's
because my hands are blood red isn't it
I don't understand it's very strange but
I know it's very strange like for
example I'll get it like a person who's
like an amateur like an amateur
photographer try and act professional
speaking with a soft voice that could
trigger me but anyhow the most specific
on an amateur photographer who's not
very good yeah I'm having trouble with
ya or if they were like you know like
count or six somebody of doing a
technical thing like counting down like
tape recording you like I'm just gonna
count down and then we'll start three
two one go like stuff like that like
unprofessional people recording okay
it's actually like you're just in a
constant state of orgasmic joy
seriously everything you're describing
is like the refrigerator opening a
refrigerator closing someone biting into
bread someone not having bread
I'm burden the sky no birds in the sky